so when you heard about whitey bulger
being found in Santa Monica was that the
catalyst for you wanting to do the film
or had you been following his whole
story for years well interestingly well
maybe it's just interesting to me but
interestingly you know I have long been
fascinated by the Bulger saga it is an
irresistible narrative ruling over the
Boston criminal empire for 25 years not
even so much as being stopped for a
traffic ticket the FBI not bringing him
to justice pressure from the
Massachusetts State Police ultimately
belatedly forcing an investigation that
led to an indictment that in turn led to
the FBI tipping him off in him going on
the lam it's an incredible narrative and
frankly I never thought he was going to
be brought in to justice I like many
thought he was hiding in plain sight and
never to be brought in and I was also
fascinated always as a media maker at
the cottage industry of the Bulger
franchise as I story I mean I've never
seen a criminal so pass into the modern
kind of myth-making cultural machine to
the point where some people think he's a
hero and dozens of books have been
written about him and Johnny Depp is
shooting a movie and Jack Nicholson
played Bulger or some form of a Bulger
loosely based on him in the departed and
so I've been long fascinated by all
these elements but never thought I had
anything to add precisely because
there's a glut of media about the guy
each each piece with its own spin as to
who Whitey Bulger is so when he was
actually arrested as a follower of the
story I was surprised my ears then
started to prick up you know I started
to pay attention but when when it was
finally announced that he was being
actually going to be brought back to
Massachusetts and the date was announced
and he was standing trial then I thought
along with CNN
that this could be a really compelling
film that finally I would have something
to add to the story because I could use
the trial the present tense springboard
of the trial to kind of separate the man
from the myth and to really explore who
this person is versus these you know
mythologies that have been created you
know and nonfiction books I shouldn't
say everything is a mythology you know
there are people there's some legitimate
reporting that has gone on but you know
each each book kind of has its own spin
and so I wanted to use the trial to try
to understand for myself whoo-hoo Whitey
Bulger is and more importantly what
allowed him to be possible and lastly
you approached CNN films or who invested
in the film what was this well CNN films
and I were in conversation about doing a
film and this subject came up and we
both kind of just grabbed for the
opportunity so CNN films was hugely
supportive and it was good opportunity
you